talking a lot about going back to school
while going to college is a big move but
it's also a big expense indeed it is
scammers though try to take advantage of
that you know saying that they'll help
you with financial aid or scholarships
to pay your tuition Mary Jane Billy is
joining us live this morning with what
options students have when it comes to
handling College payment and and getting
back to it after what two and a half
years yeah that's absolutely right
Heather as student loan forbearance is
expected to come to an end this month
you should be aware of the many scams
associated with student loan payments
and scholarship qualifications advisors
from scholarship points a program
helping students plan and pay for
college say scholarship and financial
aid scans may come in the form of social
media posts email or even a letter it
might look like a personalized
invitation saying you've been selected
for a specific scholarship or a
financial aid package students may be
easy victims because now is a vulnerable
time for those who have to repay their
loans or have accumulating debt
through people who email you text you
their online ads so certainly look for
red flags when you're looking for
scholarship if they're asking you to pay
for a scholarship or guarantee a
scholarship for a small fee or required
you to provide bank account those are
all major red flags when you're all done
with school you know there's this
happiness and um
just relief that it's all done and you
feel so accomplished but then at the
same time you just feel drowning in debt
and don't know what to do
education Consultants say always do your
research and pick reputable student loan
and scholarship companies and always
stay up to date with your current
scholarship or financial aid
applications and never share your
personal school information with anyone
over the phone or online reporting Live
From The Newsroom Mary Jane beliesza
live local now